[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen was kurz
vor Weihnachten im Sport los war das
erfahren Sie von S Foss mit Snowboard
Darts und Handball guten Abend kommen
wir zu unseren Nachrichten
Themen keine Atempause in Gaza die
Kämpfe in Gaza gehen auch nach
unrolution weiter die humanitäre Lage
wird immer
schlimmer ein Land in Trauer nach dem
schusswaffenangriff in Prag gedenkt
Tschechien der 14 getöteten
Menschen und Hüftschwung für die
Freiheit ein älterer Iraner verstößt
öffentlich gegen das Tanzverbot und gibt
so auch der Protestbewegung neuen
Schwung die Not der Zivilbevölkerung in
Gaza ist groß auch nach der gestern
mühsam verabschiedeten Resolution des
un- Sicherheitsrates wird weiter
gekämpft und es fehlt an ausreichend
Hilfsgütern die Menschen dort hätten
tagelang nicht zu essen so die
Hilfsorganisation immerhin es kommen
jetzt wieder mehr Lastwagen mit
Hilfsgütern wie Bohnen oder Keksen
gestern waren es 69 LKW am Grenzübergang
Raffa 23 am zusätzlich geöffneten
Übergang bei Kerem schalom aber wegen
der Kämpfe können die Güter nicht
überall verteilt werden mehr von Susanna
Santina auch heute noch kommen über die
zwei geöffneten Grenzübergänge viele LKW
mit Hilfslieferung nach gasereien Hilfe
die die Menschen hier dringend brauchen
mehr als eine halbe Million ist hier von
akutem Hunger betedroht so das
Welternährungsprogramm was kommt ist
immer noch viel zu
wenig wir fordern von den Vereinten
Nationen dass sie uns Menschen in Gaza
unterstützen die Hilfe die bei uns
derzeit ankommt reicht nicht seit einem
Monat sind wir hier und bislang ist bei
uns nichts angekommen es gibt kein Essen
nichts zu trinken einfach gar nichts
bislang erschweren die fortlaufenden
Angriffe und Kämpfe die Hilfslieferungen
deswegen macht die palästinensische
Seite
Druck wir werden nicht nachgeben bis wir
eine Waffenruhe erreichen um die
dringend benötigte Hilfe für die
Palästinenser in Gaza zu
ermöglichen Israel betont dass nicht nur
den Zivilisten hier sondern auch den
Geiseln geholfen werden müsse und für
eine Waffenruhe gebe es
Bedingungen wenn es eine Waffenruhe
geben soll dann ist für uns entscheidend
dass Geiseln freigelassen werden es gibt
eine Chance weil Hamas diese Waffenruhe
will diese Waffenruhe braucht für die
Menschen in Gaza wird die medizinische
Versorgung immer schwieriger im Norden
kann kein einziges Krankenhaus mehr
arbeiten alle anderen sind wegen der
vielen Verletzten am Limit wir haben
dieses Kind aus den trübern eines
zerbomten Hauses geborgen zum Glück geht
es ihm gut in Tel demonstrierenele
Angehörige der Geiseln wie jeden Samstag
auch heute sie alle fordern ein neues
Abkommen mit der
Hamas mit der Resolution des un
Sicherheitsrates sind ja Hoffnung
verknüpft Susanna Santina was bewegt
sich jetzt tatsächlich seit der
Verabschiedung die Hoffnung ist
natürlich dass eben durch eine
Waffenruhe mehr Hilfe nach Gaser
reinkommen kann besser verteilt werden
kann fest steht ja dass die Hilfe bei
weitem nicht ausreicht viele Menschen
haben uns in Gasa erzählt dass sie
Hunger leiden aber die Chancen für eine
Waffenruhe die stehen tatsächlich
schlecht weil die Position zwischen
Hamas und israelischeer Regierung zu
weit voneinander entfernt sind die Hamas
ist nicht zu einer Waffenruhe bereit sie
sagen wir wollen ein Ende der Kämpfe des
Krieges und die israelische Regierung
ist nur zu einer Waffenruhe bereit wenn
die Hamas Geiseln befreit also man kann
wirklich sagen dass sich diese
Positionen immer noch mehr voneinander
entfernt haben und die leitragen sind
natürlich die Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
die dringend auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
aber auch die Geiseln und und ihre
Familien denn mit einer schnellen
Freilassung ist im Moment nicht zu
rechnen danke Susanna
Santina das Massaker das die Hamas am 7
oktober in Israel verübt hat hat das
Land traumatisiert fast jeder Israeli
kennt jemanden der an dem Tag ermordet
oder von der terrormiliz verschleppt
wurde Henriette de mesia hat Israelis in
diesen Kriegszeiten bei einem
Klassentreffen begleitet viele ehemalige
Mitschüler und Mitschülerinnen
fehlten Klassentreffen nach 20 Jahren
sie lachen über die Fotos erzählen was
inzwischen passiert ist und beklagen
ihre Toten und Vermissten vom 7 Oktober
wir wollen einfach nur noch einmal alle
zusammen sein die Gefühle die wir jetzt
Teilen jeder hier wir alle haben einiges
durchgemacht wir sind durch die Hölle
gegangen es gibt ein Video des Jahrgangs
2003 es zeigt das Jahrbuch der Schule
mal habsor nah des
gaserreifens auf dem Klassenfoto am Rand
wie immer die Lehrerin rotem Calderon
sie wurde am 7 oktober im kibutzie von
der Hamas
erschossen drei Männer aus dem Jahrgang
sind in den Händen der Hamas Tamir mit
dem großen Lachen der damals träumte in
Jamaika zu sein ist jetzt in Gaza
genauso
wie it der so sensibel ist wurde
verschleppt nachdem seine Eltern beide
ermordet
wurden wir haben unseren ersten
zusammebacken und ruinierten den
Backofen liras verschanzte sich 26
Stunden im Schutzraum vor der Hamas
amids Eltern und Großeltern wurden
ermordet nicht nur Familien starben auch
jarons
Hund es ist so ein unglaubliches Gefühl
Leben in diese Welt zu bringen
einerseits ist dieses Glück und
gleichzeitig ist alles in dunkle Farben
getaucht manchmal habe ich Schuldgefühle
weil ich so glücklich
eine ehemalige Schulklasse die wie ein
Brennglas für das Schicksal vieler
Menschen in Israel
steht der Antisemitismus Beauftragte der
Bundesregierung klein hat sich besorgt
zur Sicherheitslage von Jüdinnen und
Juden in Deutschland geäußert seit dem
Holocaust seien so sie nicht mehr in so
großer Gefahr gewesen wie heute sagte
Klein den funkezeitungen wie die Welt
berichtet hat es laut Bundeskriminalamt
seit dem 7 Oktober mehr als 1000
Straftaten mit antisemitischem
Hintergrund
gegeben einkommensschwache Familien
können neben dem Kindergeld auch einen
Kinderzuschlag erhalten bis lang sind
das maximal 250 € im neuen Jahr soll es
mehr werden der Höchstbetrag steigt auf
292 € pro Monat Familien mit geringem
Einkommen könnten dann zusammen mit dem
Kindergeld mit bis zu 500 42 € pro Kind
rechnen sagte Familienministerin Paus
der Augsburger allgemein beide
Leistungen sollen
2025 in der Kindergrundsicherung
Aufgehen in der Ukraine ist ein hoher
Beamter des
Verteidigungsministeriums wegen Betrugs
festgenommen worden er soll daran
beteiligt gewesen sein beim Einkauf von
Artilleriemunition umgerechnet rund 36
Millionen Euro veruntreut zu haben im
Osten der Ukraine im Gebiet J versucht
Russland weiter die Stadt aufdiivka
einzukreisen neue Angriffe dort Werten
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte nach
eigenen Angaben
ab früher wurde in der Ukraine im Januar
Weihnachten gefeiert damit ist seit
diesem Jahr auch offiziell Schluss man
will weg von russischen Gepflogenheiten
und feiert wie es der großerzbischof von
kieff ausdrückte zusammen mit der ganzen
Welt wie ist die Stimmung an den Tagen
vor dem Fest Alisa jung hat sich einen
Eindruck verschafft Weihnachten in der
Ukraine das heißt ein zweites Mal
Weihnachten im
Krieg bislang waren die Traditionen ein
Mix aus katholisch ukrainisch und
russisch orthodox von letzteren wollen
sie sich nun lösen die Regierung hat
entschieden Weihnachten soll am 25
Dezember statt am 7 januar gefeiert
werden die Gläubigen wollten das selbst
sie wollen mit der europäischen Welt
einheitlich sein denn in Europa wird
bekanntlich am 25 gefeiert
auch hja die Dula fährt nun früher als
sonst von Kiev zu den Eltern nach
Lemberg um am 25 zu Feier ihre Familie
wie die vier Ukrainerinnen ist in diesem
Jahr nicht
komplett dieses Jahr ist alles anders
weil niemand von meinen fünf
Geschwistern zu Hause sein
wird zwei meiner Brüder kämpfen in der
Armee und können nicht für Weihnachten
nach Hause
kommen eine meiner Schwestern ist in
Italien auf einer christlichen Mission
um den Verlust ihres Verlobten zu
verarbeiten er starb an der Front der
Mann der zweiten Schwester kämpft noch
auseinandergerissene Familien leere
Stühle Frieden an Weihnachten dieser
Wunsch hat sich für die Ukrainer nicht
erfüllt die Geburt Jesu damals wie heute
gibt uns Hoffnung dass das Gute das Böse
überwinden
wird die Hoffnung nicht verlieren das
ist ihre Botschaft
in Tschechien herrscht heute
Staatstrauer das Land gedenkte Opfer des
schusswaffenangriffs am Donnerstag an
der Prager ksuniversität um 12 Uhr
mittags hielten die Menschen bei einer
Schweigeminute inne danach läuteten
Kirchen im ganzen Land ihre Glocken der
Täter hatte 14 Menschen ermordet über
die Trauer und das Gedenken berichtet
Oliver
Flamm wie schwer muss es sein an ihre
getöteten Freunde
onen Angehörigen zu denken ein Blick in
ihre Gesichter sagt alles in diesem kaum
zu ertragenen Moment in dem die Stadt
ein ganzes Land Inn
hält am Trauergottesdienst im feizdom
Nehmen auch viele Studentinnen und
Studenten
[Musik]
Teil wenn jemand sein Leben so
unnötigerweise verliert so die Rektorin
der Universität dann dauert es sehr
lange das zu akzeptieren gerade ein
junger Mensch hätte noch so viele
Gelegenheiten gehabt anderen etwas Gutes
zu tun darum trifft uns das noch
härter noch immer wird nach dem Motiv
des 24-Jährigen Täters gesucht die
Polizei fand bei ihm weitere Waffen nur
ihr schnelles Eingreifen habe noch
Schlimmeres verhindert so die Regierung
die Tatwaffe hatte der Mann legal
gekauft eine Verschärfung der
Waffengesetze lehnte die tschechische
Regierung wie die meisten EU-Länder seit
Jahren ab bis heute können viele das
Geschehene kaum
verarbeiten unsere Nachbarin ist hier
gestorben sie war Professorin an der Uni
musikprofessorin das was hier passiert
ist Bericht mir das Herz es ist kaum zu
glauben mindestens vier Menschen wurden
inzwischen festgenommen weil sie die
Bluttat öffentlich gelobt oder ähnliche
Taten angekündigt hatten die Polizei hat
ihre Präsenz deshalb bis auf weiteres
deutlich
verstärkt
monatelang sind in Iran Massen von
Menschen gegen das Regime auf die Straße
gegangen die mullas haben mit Gewalt und
Unterdrückung darauf geantwortet jetzt
fühlt sich das Regime von einem
tanzenden älteren Mann herausgefordert
denn Tanzen verstößt gegen die
moralischen Vorstellung der mullas der
Mann ist aber längst weltweit in den
sozialen Medien und in Iran selbst ein
Hit Anna FE
berichtet das ist er der neue Hoffnung
iranesteweg ein tanzender älterer her
seine Videos millionenfach geklickt
tausende im Inn und Ausland die ihm
nacheifern dem strengen islamischen
Regime zum Trotz der Rei nach im
November beginnt der Mann der sich nennt
in seiner Heimat rascht am Kaspischen
Meer über den Fischmarkt zu tanzen er
WLE ein bisschen Glück unter die
Menschen bringen doch tanzen in der
Öffentlichkeit ist im Iran nicht erlaut
wenig überraschend die Meldung der Tanz
Rentner
sein Instagram Account gesperrt seine
Fans wollen das nicht hinnehmen und
machen boogi über Nacht weltweit zu
einer Kultfigur der Freiheit hier in
dieser Einkaufsstraße in teeran kennt
ihn heute fast
jeder sie haben ihn nur verhaftet um
ihren eigenen Glauben zu manifestieren
statt einfach den Menschen zu erlauben
so zu leben wie sie wollen die haben
Angst deshalb stoppen Sie so etwas und
die sind einfach auch generell gegen das
Glücklichsein der öffentliche Druck ist
groß die Verhaftung wird von offizieller
Stelle dementiert die Polizei sagt es
seien nur die gewarnt worden die sich
gegen die Moral Verhalten auch das
Kulturministerium macht eine zynische
kertwende dieser Tanz zeigt unsere
starke Kultur und unser kulturelles Erbe
buogi tanzt weiter doch es bleibe ein
ständiger Kampf sagt Danial Shaki er hat
ein Boogie Remix komponiert politische
Fragen könne er nicht beantworten nur so
viel für unabhängige Kunst gibt es hier
keinen Raum du brauchst starke
Verbindungen um dich
durchzusetzen oder wie buogi eine
Protestbewegung dahinter dazu gehören
mittlerweile sogar die Soldatinnen von
Irans erklärtem ernstfeind
Israel Morgen sind die Geschäfte zu also
bleibt nur noch ganz wenig Zeit für die
letzten
Weihnachtseinkäufe der Einzelhandel
hofft auf gute kau Laune bei allen die
jetzt noch Geld ausgeben und das ist
laut einer Studie immerhin jeder oder
jeder 20ste denn bisher ging die
geschäftte im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
nicht so gut der Handelsverband rechnet
mit einem Minus von
5,5%. Oliver deuka war beim Shoppen kurz
vor Schluss
dabei alle Jahre wieder für den einen
oder anderen kommt Weihnachten dann doch
ganz überraschend heute nun die letzte
Gelegenheit für Kurzentschlossene noch
ein Weihnachtsgeschenk zu ergattern
warum nur so spät man vorher keine Zeit
hat ja Unternehmer selbstständig immer
viel zu tun ich war se Wochen im Urlaub
und ja muss so ein paar Kleinigkeiten
erledigen aber ich weiß was ich will
kleine
Kinder ganz viel Krankheiten und ja
jetzt muss ich leider auf den letzten
Drücker los alles andere als ideal die
Einkaufsbedingungen heute in Hannover
schiedwetter und dann auch noch Streik
im Einzelhandel ausgerechnet einen Tag
vor Heiligabend muss das sein es musste
leider sein weil die Arbeitgeber uns
seit mehr als 7 Monaten hinhalten wir
haben immer noch keinen
Tarifabschluss hier geht alles seinen
Gang keiner streigt entspanntes Shoppen
und was wird noch so auf den letzten
Drücker besorgt auf jeden Fall ein
Gutschein kauftter immer es werden
Handtaschen gekauft für die Frauen
Geldbörsen Schuhe auch unter anderem und
ganz beliebt sind die Bildbände für
städteeisen das ultimative Geschenk für
Mann oder Frau es zu finden es zu kaufen
alle Jahre wieder die gleiche
Herausforderung immerhin eine konstante
zum Ende des
Jahres Sturmtief soltarn ist
mittlerweile über Deutschland hin
weggezogen doch das Wetter macht weiter
Probleme hier in berenstein im
Erzgebirge schneit es seit dem Morgen
heftig eine Menge Arbeit für den
Winterdienst in diesen Stunden setzt
dort allerdings Tauwetter ein und
Dauerregen in vielen Teilen Deutschlands
wie hier in Altena im Sauerland die
länne trat über die Ufer Häuser standen
unter
Wasser und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport
kurz vor Weihnachten mussten die
Snowboarder und Snowboarderin noch mal
ran und sen einer hat mal wieder
geliefert oder das kann man wohl so
sagen Ramona Hofmeister hat sich heute
schon ein vorgezogenes
Weihnachtsgeschenk gemacht die
27-Jährige aus Bischofswiesen setzte
ihre perfekte Saison fort in Davos holte
sie bereits den 18 Weltcupsieg ihrer
Karriere schon wieder darf sie jubeln
Ramona Hofmeister gewinnt ihren dritten
Weltcup nacheinander die Olympia dritte
aus Bischofswiesen hier rechts fährt im
Finale gegen die Italienerin Lucia
dalmasso im snowbard parallel Slalom um
den Sieg zuvor gewann sie bereits die
Weltcups in kzza und Cortina dampzzo im
parallel Riesenslalom Hofmeister
entscheidet das Rennen knapp für sich
mit 29 h Vorsprung bra Pause gerade gar
nicht ich f mich eher bereit für die
nächsten Rennen schade für sie der
Weltcup pausiert bis Mitte
Januar und noch eine Meldung vom Fußball
Manchester City ist clubweltmeister das
Team von pep Guardiola gewann im Finale
4:0 gegen Fluminense aus Rio de Janeiro
für den englischen Meister ist es der
fünfte Titel im laufenden
Jahr vier Deutsche unter den besten 32
das gab es noch nie bei der Dartz WM
nachdem die deutsche Nummer 1 Gabriel
kemens vorgelegt hatte zog mit Ricardo
pietrezko heute der vierte deutsche
Profi in die nächste Runde
ein das Duell Ricardo pietrezco gegen
callen Ritz lange Zeit hochklassig und
ausgeglichen 22 nach Sätzen der fünfte
muss entscheiden dort ist der Berliner
petrezzko ganz cool wirft 129 Punkte und
lässt seinem englischen Gegner fort an
keine Chance vor allem die starke
Trefferquote auf die doppelfelder bringt
p den Sieg schon gestern zieht Martin
Schindler in die Runde der letzten 32
ein der Strausberger besiegte
Niederländer germain what hoch emotional
geht zu bei Florian Hempel aus Dessau
gegen Dimitri fandenberg schon fast raus
der Belgier verpasst den matchstart der
Deutsche unter Druck wirft 151 Punkte
Hempel dem vorher wenig glückt dreht die
Partie und ist ein von vier Deutschen
für die es nach Weihnachten weitergeht
im in
aber erst nach Weihnachten Willand
Schmidt war der beste Handballtorwart
seiner Zeit 1980 führte der gebürtige
Magdeburger die DDR Auswahl zu olympiaag
heute feiert er seinen 70 Geburtstag dem
Handball ist der treu
geblieben Handball bleibt seine
Leidenschaft als Torwarttrainer des
frauenzweitligisten Leipzig eine Szene
vor 43 Jahren hat williland Schmidt zur
Ikone des deutschen Sports gemacht seine
fabelhafte Parade in den Schlusssekunden
des Olymp Finales 1980 in Moskau gegen
die UdSSR Olympia Gold für die DDR noch
immer denkt der bescheidene Sportler
manchmaland hast ein bisschen was
erreicht und das war toll gewesen und
ich habe ganz ganz viele Leute glücklich
gemacht olympiaseger bei
Weltmeisterschaften zweiter und dritter
Europapokalsieger mit dem SC Magdeburg
Schmidt galt als bester Handballtorwart
der Welt und ihn begeistert sein Sport
auch mit 70 in zwei Wochen hat er das
nächste Spiel mit den
Leipzigerinnen
wir sagen herzlichen Glückwunsch das
war's vom Sport J danke schön Sven
weihnachtsdingen im Fußballstadion
Besinnlichkeit stad beinharter
Wettkämpfe das gibt's inzwischen bei
einigen Clubs aber bei Union Berlin
schon seit 2003 die sanfte Tradition der
eisernen sie findet seit ein paar
Minuten statt und wir schauen jetzt und
hören jetzt mal live
rein sind
die zündet Freude sieh in jeden Raum
Weihnachtsfreude wir verkündet unter
jedem
lchterbum Leuchten nicht mit hen schin
überall
überall soll
Freude
sein sü tausende beim weihnachtssing von
Union Berlin kommen wir noch zum Wetter
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt weiter
vor Dauerregen in Teilen von
Niedersachsen Hessen Nordrhein-Westfalen
rheinlandfalz und Bayern außerdem wir
haben es gesehen vor starkem Schneefall
im Erzgebirge Details zum Wetter gleich
östen terli für Sie das heute journal
können Sie gegen 23:15 Uhr sehen mit
Dunja Hayali ein schönen Abend
[Musik]
noch
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter im Osten
Deutschlands gibt es tatsächlich noch
Kaltluft und die sorgt auch noch für
etwas Schnee bis in die Frühstunden und
dann taut das relativ rasch Weg denn es
kommt mildere Luft Regen und wieder Wind
auf in der Nacht also im Osten etwas
Schneefall und die Schneedecke kann sich
durchaus ausbilden sehr viel wird's
nicht sein aber für glatte Straßen kann
es sorgen sonst aber so viel Regen
teilweise ergiebig im Süden erstmal
trocken bei tiefsten Temperaturen von
-1° im Osten also allein wegen der
Temperaturen kann es also schon glätze
geben 9° ganz im Westen Deutschlands
morgen dann im Osten letzte
Schneeflocken und dann verschwindet das
schon den Frühstunden ansonsten Regen
von Westen her es kann ergiebig regnen
und ganz im Süden da kann mal die Sonne
hervorblinzeln bei Temperaturen von 7
bis 13° also weiße Weihnachten ist kein
Thema die Aussichten der erste Feiertag
mit regenurchwachsen bei 7 bis 13°
danach etwas kühler aber Schnee ist
nicht mehr dabei damit einen schönen
Abend und schöne
Feiertage